[Music]
keep seven nominations tonight the most
nominated artist how's it feel
incredible it's never happened to me
ever
no that's absolute first I can't believe
no the success of this album records
been beyond anything we could have
imagined so well does that how proud are
you Nepal amazed I mean I've seen him do
it over and over again and here but it
comes down to I think his passion if you
have passion and love for what you do
and that will carry you carry you
through anything yeah
where do you keep your trophies at home
because you have a few already yeah I
have a lot of my closet yeah and and my
mom has a lot too she's really sweet she
loves him yeah yeah now I have to ask
you about these idol coming back rumors
have you heard anything have they
contacted you no not as yet what did why
what have you heard they're saying it's
coming back you know come on I daren't
seriously do you ever go back to that
show it's too I've got questions for the
questions yeah but I loved doing it I
really did I loved it I love the
camaraderie with Harry and Jenna and
Ryan yeah I miss that
yeah you just jammed with Harry recently
I'm good on Harry show yeah that was fun
yeah very fun have you seen JLo in Vegas
yet yes Nick loved it my sister and I
came it was my big present to my sister
and she's amazing I mean you've got to
see her show she's amazing I can't wait
tell me you had all the backstage passes
and all that good stuff I did hahahahaha
you got a hang with Jenny um and she's
beautiful backstage as she is on stage
I mean she's yeah she's like a she's a
goddess tell me about your dress I'm
getting the wrap up but I cannot ignore
how beautiful this is it's Alexander
McQueen yeah I'm lucky I got to put it
on and wear it and it's yet
it's pretty so what do you think he a
beautiful beautiful the dress is nice
too it's comfortable
[Music]